now up to 40 people died and dozens were
injured in a blaze in a residential
building in southern taiwan that's
according to the fire department the
13-story building in the city of
kaohsiung caught fire in the early hours
of the morning it's not known what
sparked the blaze
search and rescue operations are now
underway
for more we're joined now by our
correspondent joyce lee in taipei joyce
what else do we know about this fire at
this point
so at this point 66 people have been
taken to the hospital and
unfortunately 11 bodies were sent
directly to the funeral home and
more than 40 people showed no signs of
life and in taiwan the official
confirmation of a death can only be made
in the hospital so we are still waiting
for the latest number of death toll um
and uh the oldest um
uh you know survivor
that got rescued is a 83 year old woman
and the youngest one is a eight-year-old
girl and uh the building is about 40
years old and
a lot of the residents are elderly
people so um the fire fighters are still
trying to rescue more people and
a lot of
junks
were blocking the staircase so it made
the rescue work
more difficult
joyce thank you very much that was dw
correspondent joyce lee there in taipei